so hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
spooky things spooky things spooky thing
anyway so this is starting off with
apartment 3 906 there's supposed to be a
short horror game that's about an
apartment which is not an uncommon
setting that I've seen before click to
take pictures that's also something I've
seen before but we'll see how you do it
look for and gather evidence evidence so
why was there a murder did somebody die
alright oh now that's what I call the
picture oh whoa is that blood
were those just paintings no those are
just paintings I thought it was blitt
what oh that's the chair no I saw shadow
moving in the darkness I assumed it was
something trying to kill me don't know I
assume that that's a weird thing to
assume in this place Oh Beach week okay
Oh what did I do what the candles go
away
this is some flash poof evidence is some
kind of dinner doesn't seem to be any
kind of oven in this kitchen
no stovetop no nothing they must just
have a George Foreman they bust out
every once in a while how about you
pokey a dirty clock monkey no what about
that clown clown don't look too good
trust no clown nope that clown fine
oh god no wait is that looks familiar
it's from another game isn't it no I
don't remember I go through doors no I'm
stuck did something change like
something changed right what's that I
took a picture of that and then the
candles moved so I'm assuming that
something changed hello in the fridge
I'm honky can I know all right so now
I'm just a little confused what does it
want me to do there's nothing I can use
there's just just a rumor
okay this is a little odd I'm at a bit
of a loss but not the worst thing ever
I'm assuming I just got to take the
picture of the right thing there's got
to be something in here that it wants me
to take a picture of and it's probably a
little bit finicky about what that is
st. fatal frame
where it's gonna judge me on the
composition to the picture but probably
is like oh what oh I was I even looked
at Oh God this is okay this looks bad on
me yeah that's it Oh oh [ __ ]
so the reticle turns gold green when
there's something of worth to be shot
well that's new oh why why this three
murdered killers still at large I think
I've read this paper before four
murdered still at hey hey buddy hey hey
buddy hey buddy hey who is there huh
who's there oh yeah okay all right oh
you okay all right well I'm ready for
whatever you're gonna dish out to me oh
all right
who did it who did it oh that's not good
hey wait a minute hey wait a minute hey
wait a minute oh it's dark over here oh
no oh it's just shadows it's just
horrible shadows Hey what what is it you
yeah oh okay all right wait a minute hey
wait about it Hey
hey is that a knocking is that a knock
knock knock on the cellar door sound one
of those rap pop pops oh oh oh
something went awry this don't seem
quite the same all right
Wow it is it's a rap papa hello
does your no it's not delivery oh [ __ ]
no that's not a good job
oh I'm dead well there you have it I'm
dead great I love that actually that was
pretty good that was pretty good for my
own stupidity got me lost there but that
was just my fault not the game's fault
definitely my fault so I will take the
blame for that 100% that is entirely my
fault but Britney dese all right so this
came Oh
hey is my flash charged up daisies farm
Oh
all right Daisy oh hey see oh my Daisy
your music is so ominous I like it
oh don't like that oh god I don't like
that it's dusk on Daisy's farm and the
mined fruit is ready for harvest oh yeah
the mined fruit we all know it we all
love it this is what it looks like huh
pretty good right okay anyway collect
the ripe orange mined fruit as quickly
as you can move too slow and you'll be
food for the crows once the mine fruit
bar is appeared you'll only have a few
seconds to pick it before it spoils even
if one mine fruit spoils death will fall
Oh perfect perfect that was hoping for
that I have multiple questions I'm very
confused
okay-y seconds why does it spoil so fast
why does death follow or whatever let's
do this Oh Daisy
Oh Daisy
Oh Daisy Oh Daisy it's all I mean you
still got that whole mouth so oh no I
don't want to find out actually I don't
why do I do I got a harvest ten fast
[Music]
okay Oh
why do you gotta say naughty boy he's
like some perverted horror version of
farmville ooh where the noise is so
weird why are you so weird
so who tied you up there this is just a
hobby of yours to be tied up like that
okay all right you know what it's fine
don't answer me
you're real talkative before I don't
even know how I got here I sure AM yes I
am oh okay all right you're not gonna
tell me to go drop off all right Daisy
okay good talk Thanks yeah thank you
I'll just I'll put him in the bucket
yeah there we go
floppy
fill your wrath is that a threat or a
promise your friggin weirdo
okay oh no wait hang on whoa wait hang
on
wait what there were two cuz they're
fake is there a fake mine fruit so like
a power fruit is this like the infinity
fruits am I trying to collect all the
colors of the fruits I'm about tasting
the rainbow I'm not on represent sure
what's happening Daisy says you you're
tied up you're just watching me that
crows gonna Peck your eyes out if you
even have eyes excuse me sorry Daisy
didn't mean to get that close to you we
why are you why do you have a burlap
sack for a head why are you like sack
boy but only the head portion okay all
right anyway bye Daisy I'm sure whatever
wait a minute hey that's that's not oh
good mm why is this the way that it is
huh okay well okay all right I think I
could just run around it why do I got to
run through it that's the question of
the day Oh perfectly easy the trick is
to not run through the spinning blades
of death yeah that's a smart move on my
part I'm a smart guy
full of smart things in my head Daisy I
don't like your Tater Tot
oh [ __ ] I think that there's something
left to be desired I think yeah it's
it's not good oh I'm done okay thanks
Daisy for the heads up also what's that
in the distance over there that's kind
of weird who knows what that is why is
there a cellar door here okay never mind
you know what what never ask about the
farmer I get out of here what's never
ask about the farmer no I really want to
ask about the farmer hey Daisy what
happened to the farmer
watch what the crows are watching what
why are they watching whoa easy-peasy Oh
where'd it where is it where is it I
don't see oh [ __ ]
no give it to me I got it I got it oh
wait I got it okay the crows did they
see that huh did you see it daizy pretty
cool right
why like a hoe all right well not that
bad what huh wait wait whoa hey whoa
what's with that double harvest thing oh
[ __ ] where is it give it to me where is
it oh it's not there oh okay all right
touch it no [ __ ] oh God oh I met a man I
cheated I clearly didn't cheat didn't
you hear the screams of terror and also
what are those things what's with those
I don't know what those are about I
don't like slice and dice I thought that
was gonna get me yeah you're right oh
you're making it easy Oh No hey wait
come on now I didn't that wasn't fair
that wasn't fair hang on wait wait all
right anyway so uh yeah I'm not gonna do
that again because number one I don't
feel like it and number two I don't feel
like but not bad like it's an
interesting game concept like the whole
collecting and avoid death it kind of
reminds me of a killing floor you know
you know that kind of just look random
thing but thanks Daisy it was good mean
yeah Daisy you're kind of weird and
horribly disturbing and you don't really
have those but you know that I don't
want to point out anyone's personal
problems so and to be honest the whole
toe thing is the least of your concerns
at this juncture so I'm gonna get out
here
you have good time I'll see you in the
next farm uh later that was interesting
number one that was interesting number
two that was interesting different
concept but I I felt no compulsion to go
back to the beginning and play through
it again so we're gonna move on alright
so this one is called paranoid games
still under development or the controls
walk and run well it's that easy all
right let's do this come on I'm ready
for this
hello chapter one whom well it's an
elevator that makes a lot more sense I
thought it was just a weird metal box
hello hello hmm hello I wasn't in the
control list oh nice I guess
alright okay I see you oh sweet I keep
my Saudis outside of the fridge I'm such
a rebel I'm such a badass I'm gonna
renovate the entire industry hello
nothing okay that's just a weird window
it's on my patio I'm guessing but
doesn't seem like that
hello oh no I broke up or I've been
broke up with hello well you know I'm
not that tired to be perfectly honest
well thing I need sleep that badly I
don't think I need a shower this badly
either alright well that's weird
let's just go into the bedroom you sack
of [ __ ]
no not really I can't see nothing it was
real dark in here hello alright well I
guess that's a whole lot of nothing then
hey is there anybody in here that I need
to see okay hmm
sorry I can't hear you you're breaking
up how many of you guys at home think
that this is a bad thing or this is a
friend desperately trying to get in
touch with us and warn us that something
bad is going on or just trying to get in
touch with us trying to catch up finally
reaching out phone doesn't work such a
tragedy well what happened what happened
oh oh no this is not your home well okay
all right well that's just a then that's
just a misunderstanding I should have
known my tea isn't right-side up in this
place
how's my bad thanks for pointing out the
error of my way well whoa get Oh that
didn't make sense to what wait hang on a
second Oh
all right this is not your home you face
booby I'm assuming I need to follow that
my buddy lady oh no lady
he's dead oh okay he's back ah
that's weird did I just make a goof that
goof it did I make the big goof I'd like
to go home I'd like to contact the wait
a minute hang on a second to normal
pretty sure that ain't something that's
supposed to happen so let's just see
won't we
laughs [ __ ]
I hate you okay all right
yeah all right oh I got a bone to pick
mouth Frick well there what the heck and
what
oh wait what well what the heck Oh what
ah I fell I fell I fell this was a bad
move
all right let's go back in uh all right
I'll be right back I'll disrespect that
was very dumb of me I will up I will
admit real dumb
that was very dumb I should I should
have been better about that okay I'll be
right back all right well there you are
I got a bone to pick with you come back
here you
oh you think you're gonna open an
elevator for me no lemon lemon all right
if you won't let me in I'll have to let
myself in whoa okay whoa whoa whoa hi
okay hmm something
[Music]
okay wasn't trying to he's trying to
find my apartment I keep finding the
wrong one what do we got here oh all
right brah it's bright oh it's my
apartment
Wow let's go to bed not what kid can't
go to bed alright no going to bed huh
alright well tippity-top down the stair
II where ZZZ that's a light I think
that's important
oh no what have I done this is a really
cool aesthetic I really like the visual
this place it's kind of funkalicious I
don't know if funkalicious is the
appropriate term to use but to me it's
funkalicious thanks for putting a dot in
the center of my screen nice windows oh
hey it's you how are you doing hey come
over here
well I got a bone to pick with you you
jump scared me last time and I didn't
much do like it so I need to go talk to
you oh don't turn your weird face on me
and do that that's just uh that's
uncomfortable that seems lovely oh this
is this isn't a sec beautiful in here
it's beautiful he's very beautiful very
very very beautiful very beautiful very
beautiful very beautiful very very
illustrious leave eautiful very very
delightfully beautiful beautiful it's
it's beautiful in fact it's it's
gloriously beautiful hello my chair how
you doing hey long time no see why
aren't you why are you out of amnesia
hello table how you doing I could chain
you okay it's a maze um I don't know
where the hell I'm supposed to go nice
triangle if the objective was to get me
lost you really succeeded I'm
help goddamn you um hi okay I have no
idea what you're talking about
II I don't speak because you didn't let
me speak I was trying to say hi and then
nothing happens so I'm just gonna leave
an end goodbye All Right see you goodbye
goodbye Hey look bright light hey the
door route was over here the whole time
you could oh wow no it's a Slenderman
game it's turned into the saloon D
saloon Dee's Castle Oh
I guess I could see it all now the the
aesthetic it's so pleasantly perfect
with his tie and his glorious demeanor
in the original originator of chromatic
aberration okay so I just gotta go back
well good thing I know the layout of
this place so particularly ain't never
gonna be lost I'm never gonna find a key
either Oh key all right one two buckle
my shoe hello that explains why there
were all the nooks and the crannies ah
well maybe it only spawns one at a time
cuz I thought I was here before but I
didn't see that one oh I've been at this
so long the music just cut out and
looped around again hey Lexi can you cut
out this music and replace it with
something a little more festive you know
something really lighten up the moods
because I think I think I think that's
what we're missing here it's just it's
too glum this place really needs like an
oompa sound
yeah yeah that's the yeah yeah that's
good that makes me feel better I'm just
I'm just moonwalking out of here just
cuz I'm like I realize I actually don't
have to participate in this weird game
of ladies I'm just seeing if they had
the key at the beginning of the level
which they did not answer that question
glad I did all right put the music back
if I was a key and I was the last key I
had to get I would be in the room where
that guy is and he's now dead that seems
like something this game would pull I go
back here I go like I can't find the
fifth key but he's dead oh he's not dead
I mean yeah you're not dead I guess yeah
I shouldn't be happy or sad that you're
not dead so I got probably be happy no
anyway good talk love our talks where is
this key Oh God gotcha all right okay
got him I don't know how I'm gonna fit
these keys into a door made of light
button you know I'm gonna try guess hope
nothing bad happens hey you dead now now
that got all the keys hey buddy I'm
celebrating I got the keys sorry you
don't carry taking a perpetual pill hey
that's a cool aesthetic that's so cool
that's such a cool Fedak that's so cool
look at that that's thumbnail worthy
that's so cool no I love triangles
double can hang all right okay hey wait
a minute no you said it was the
beginning you lied this is the end you
lied you lied to me you lied you're a
lie
you're a liar you lied to me all right
so that was paranoid started out really
good and strong I like the the modified
hallways and all I love that [ __ ] I love
when the environments change I love just
like throwing things off like that um
however the end was there's a lot of
times when horror games do often devolve
into find X number of X to progress and
it it is a bit hampering there there are
times when it's good and it's helpful
like if
there's a story reason behind it but
there's no story reason for a bright
white wall to be like go find these days
but that's not saying it was bad but
still not bad like it did scare me a
couple times so that was three scary
again thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to see more scary
games look in the description click
right down there read more or above the
description look for a playlist that has
all the scary games I've ever played
over the past seven years so check it
out there and if you want me to play
more games and you got an idea of what
they are let me know down in the
comments below thank you everybody so
much for watching
and as always see you
[Music]